[Música]
soy médica geriatras por el gran amor a
mis abuelos
y mi abuela padecía la enfermedad de
alzheimer solo que yo cuando era chica
no lo sabía pensábamos que se trataba de
demencia senil o de arteriosclerosis
términos que no ayudaban ni aclaraban
nada
esa es una pregunta y no es necesario
que me respondan sino que lo piensen
para ustedes mismos
conocen a alguien que tiene demencia
conocen a alguien que tenga alzhéimer u
otro tipo de demencia
quizás eran conocidas sé que puede sonar
muy rara la pregunta pero no debería
hacerlo y saben porque es muy frecuente
esta enfermedad
tanto es así que una de cada diez
personas de 60 años la padece y casi un
millón de argentinos está afectado por
esta enfermedad
vivimos mucho más que antes unos 35 años
más en promedio que a principios del
siglo pasado donde la esperanza de vida
era de 48 años y hoy es de alrededor de
80 de hecho según la organización
mundial de la salud uno de cada dos
niños que ha nacido desde el 2014 en
adelante va a cumplir 100 años la mitad
de los niños que está naciendo va a
cumplir 100 años
y frente a este panorama estamos viendo
experimentando enfermedades que son
crónicas que son degenerativas como es
el alzhéimer y que llevan a la
discapacidad que antes no llegábamos a
dar
les quiero compartir dos experiencias
del consultorio
se acerca a la esposa de un señor que
aún no conozco que me dice doctora lo
traes a mi marido para poder hablar bien
de lo que a él le pasa
este señor se jubiló recientemente como
docente e investigador en el campo de la
biotecnología
unos meses atrás
pero hacía tiempo que su familia y sus
alumnos no notaban distintos
reiterativos a veces confuso la esposa
me dice doctor a mi marido cambio de a
poco dejó de ser l compensó confundir
días horarios nombres cuando conozco al
paciente un hombre muy inteligente y
badia mis respuestas o mis preguntas con
inteligentes respuestas cómo está su
memoria
no la necesito tanto ya no trabajo
pero cuando le pregunto qué día eso hoy
me contesta que eran 10 años atrás y en
donde estamos en una iglesia y era en el
consultorio
otra situación una hija de unos 35 años
en la sala de espera lloraba muy
angustiada cuando ingresa me dice mi
vida es un caos no sé qué hacer soy hija
única mi mamá en viuda o muy joven
siempre fue un roble inteligente fuerte
independiente y ahora la veo tan
disminuida reiterativa incluso cree que
todos le roban convenció a dos amigas
del edificio de que yo le robaba su
jubilación y me hizo una denuncia
policial por robo
está clara en ambas situaciones cuáles
son los pacientes es el profesor ese
catedrático brillante y esta madre y
esos son los pacientes ambos con
diagnósticos de enfermedad de alzheimer
pero hay dos figuras más en estas
escenas que también son pacientes solo
que ocultos de la enfermedad no son los
que se sientan en el consultorio
adelante nuestro son los que se sientan
al costado que necesitan de igual
atención contención y apoyo son esa
esposa y esta hija
y si nos preguntamos quienes cuidan
fundamentalmente a las personas que
padecen demencia
las familias
en los primeros momentos ese cuidador
familiar surge de manera espontánea en
general suele tratarse de una mujer la
esposa o la hija de los pacientes vemos
que el rol de atención y de cuidado por
lo menos en nuestra cultura es así somos
las mujeres principalmente las que
cumplimos este rol de cuidado
hace poco se acercaron al consultorio
los hijos de una señora que vive en
buenos aires- muy preocupados por el
estado de salud de su mamá
hablaban telefónicamente con ella casi
todos los días pero ya siempre se
quejaba de que tenía frío de que no la
llamaba nunca que hacía como un mes que
no lo habían llamado
quizás son situaciones que pueden pasar
que yo cuando sea madre el día de mañana
lo haga con mis hijos pero en este caso
les llama mucho la atención a estos
hijos siempre que tenía frío más de una
vez le cortaron algún servicio por no
pagar tenía todo en débito automático ya
esta mujer cuando viajan estos hijos a
buenos aires el panorama que se
encuentran es desolador su mamá estaba
muy delgada no adecuadamente higienizada
la heladera vacía y la alacena llena
pero solo de galletitas y esa quejándose
de frío se paraba
frente al calefactor que estaba apagado
si los cuidadores sin estas familias las
personas que padecen demencia no
tomarían correctamente los remedios no
comerían bien no sé no sé abrigar ian
como corresponde y un largo largo
etcétera
mientras que el mundo médico científico
sigue en la búsqueda de la cura de esta
enfermedad las personas con demencia
viven en base los cuidados
proporcionados por sus familias por esos
cuidadores que también son pacientes
cuando se le diagnostica a un ser
querido esta enfermedad es un golpe muy
duro
es muy duro reconocer que esa persona
que no conocía sea mamá sea papá esposo
esposa mi abuela dejará de ser la misma
que uno conoció hay un duelo que
atravesar
y en este tiempo en este camino uno se
enfrenta a muchas emociones y
sentimientos
algunos son positivos como la
satisfacción por contribuir con el
bienestar del ser querido pero
lamentablemente abundan los sentimientos
negativos en la primera situación que
les conté esa esposa sentía mucha
tristeza de ver así a su marido
impotencia por no poder hacer más para
que él esté mejor
ella se había aislado socialmente de sus
amigas había dejado de salir había
dejado hacer actividad física que
también le hacía porque en su imaginario
existía la creencia de que como ella
nadie lo iba a cuidar y esto le generaba
ambivalencia
por un lado bronca y por el otro lado
culpa
en la segunda situación que les relaté
recién esa hija docente de primaria
trabajaba dos turnos
nolan harían ayuno la tarde situación
habitual pero tuvo que renunciar a uno
de esos dos trabajos para cuidar a su
mamá es decir menos ingresos económicos
y más desgaste por el tiempo dispensado
cuidando a su mami
el cambio en lo cotidiano
a sumado a las tareas de atención de los
seres queridos que padecen demencia
puede generar lo que conocemos como
sobrecarga del cuidador o estrés y
conocemos principalmente tres tipos de
sobrecarga por un lado la sobrecarga
psicológica los cuidadores padecen más
trastornos de ansiedad más depresión mas
insomnio cambios bruscos de humor y
aislamiento de su entorno
en segundo lugar la sobrecarga física
los cuidadores suelen asistir a sus
familiares en la higiene en la
movilización en el traslado y esto
genera tendinitis dolores musculares
cansancio físico también y la tercera
sobrecarga y no menor no por eso menos
importante es la sobrecarga financiera
uno de cada tres cuidadores familiares
reducen en un reducen o renuncian a sus
trabajos reducen la carga horaria de
trabajo formal como vimos con esta hija
luego de 15 años de interactuar con
pacientes y con pacientes ocultos y
muchos años de haber compartido esta
enfermedad con mi abuelita me animo a
darles unos consejos
en primer lugar todo hacerlo con amor
y con humor si la abuela me preguntaba
cinco veces qué día era hoy bueno
dependiendo mi día
pero ya olvidar el consejo no lo que yo
hacía
hay que responderles cinco veces qué día
es hoy y tener esa creatividad para
cambiarlas de tema y llevarlos a otro
foco pero evitar el ya te lo dije ahora
me lo preguntaste diez veces me sale
bien porque alguna vez lo habrás hecho
quizás
reconocer que la enfermedad distorsiona
al ser amado
le cambia la conducta al y cambia el
comportamiento nos responden de otra
manera imagínense esa mamá que que
denunció a su propia hija siendo que
ella gastaba esa jubilación que apenas
la hija me contó le le era suficiente
para pagar 10 días de los 30 que tiene
el mes de los gastos que generaba su
mamá
ser flexible es saber que van a haber
días buenos y días malos momentos buenos
momentos malos y una vez una hija me
dijo doctora le corrijo hay minutos
buenos y minutos malos
pedir ayuda pedir y aceptar ayuda esto
no debería ser visto como una muestra de
debilidad o de falta de amor hacia el
ser querido porque estoy pidiendo que me
dé una mano es necesario pedir y delegar
sin culpa ciertas tareas del cuidado
diario de la higiene trámites
y así tener un tiempo para uno mismo
para volver a ese hobby que ha sido
delegado relegado para tomar un café con
los amigos hoy les voy a decir algo
frívolo pero que las cuidadoras también
lo necesitan ir a la peluquería
uno necesita un tiempo para uno mismo
tiene que estar bien para poder cuidar
bien
busca redes de contención de formación
de apoyo en esos lugares uno tiende a
aprender mucho de lo que le puede dar a
alguien que dé una charla de
profesionales de la salud pero
principalmente de otras personas que
atraviesan por lo mismo por la misma
situación esos consejos son muy valiosos
esto disminuye la sobrecarga cuantas más
herramientas tiene uno menor es la
sobrecarga menor es la angustia
y vigilar la propia salud del cuidador
más de una vez le tomé la presión
arterial al hijo de una paciente que me
lo pidió porque me dijo doctor hace un
mes que no tengo tiempo de ir al médico
a buscar la receta así que no sé cómo
andaré de la presión arterial
obviamente hipertensos u otra situación
que la hija me diga de la paciente
frente a mi lectura de sus análisis a
los de mama está mucho mejor que los
míos o ya no tengo tiempo de cuidarme
los cuidadores tienen que cuidarse para
apoyar
y nosotros como sociedad como médicos no
podemos mirar a la demencia sólo desde
el paciente porque sus familiares porque
sus seres queridos también sufren
también son pacientes son los que
ocultos de la enfermedad
los cuidadores tienen que cuidarse para
cuidar y se los voy a decir tres veces
cuidar
los cuidadores tienen que
les comparto un proverbio si quieres ir
rápido ve solo pero si quieres llegar
lejos mejor ve acompañado muchas gracias
[Aplausos]